i started this race um a few days ago
feels like longer but a few days ago
because we've been going through a trust
deficit in our politics
we may have uh
issues with our currency and sound money
but we certainly have an issue with the
credibility of our government and sound
politics
and so
i ran on a ticket
to have a clean start
and i think that's what we still need
so i'm
here
saying that despite
the rumors that some of you have been
spreading
naturally fed by others of course
i'm still
in this fight
and i'm here this morning
because i think it's important that if
you're asking for people's trust
if you're asking for the credibility
or for them to have credibility in you
to lead the country
then you need to be open now of course
it's true the first stage of the
election as we all know is
300 or
more
of the most sophisticated electorate in
the united kingdom
and we all know that the next stage
is with the membership which is really
important because you've got to be
championing the values and ideas of
those who
send you here in the first place
but the next stage is about the country
and i think
what
members of parliament and what members
of the conservative party
also need to know
is that whoever it is
who they choose
as their leader at the end of this
process
is somebody who can champion those ideas
and values
in the election that's coming
in 2024
and then i hope
maybe
in 2029 as well